betting firm William Hill has been
handed a record fine for social
responsibility failures and not for the
first time shiman has more for us now
and shiman it's a Whopper it is a
Whopper it's actually the biggest
settlement that they will have to pay in
the gamblins commission histories for
two reasons it's for breaching
anti-monal money laundering laws so laws
that prohibit criminals really being
able to wash their dirty money using
gambling companies and for breaching
social responsibility laws as well and
this is because many customers were able
to gamble huge amounts of money in
really short amounts of time one example
was that a customer was able to open a
new account and spend 23 000 pounds in
20 minutes okay it's just astonishing
and another customer was able to spend
around thirty two thousand pounds in
just a couple of days all of this
without any checks so what's quite
interesting actually is that the
gambling commissioner said it could have
been a lot worse the repercussion could
have been a lot worse Andrew Rhodes said
that actually when investigating the
feelings they'd seriously considered
whether or not to revoke William Hill's
license because of these breaches yeah
but he continued saying that because the
operator immediately recognized their
failings and worked with us they did
instead to opt for the largest
enforcement in their history and of
course like you said it isn't the first
time they weren't fined in 2018 but I
believe that was only for around 6
million pounds so this is a
substantially this is the Hut on the
hills of two gambling firms yes just
last week and we have actually had a
statement from the companies that own
William Hill as well they said the
spokesperson is for 888 that's the
company that owns William Hill that says
the settlement relates to a period when
William Hill was under previous
ownership and management after William
Hill was acquired the company quickly
addressed the identified issues with the
implementation of a rigorous action plan
okay for now thanks very much indeed
indeed there's a lot talking about of
course there are Charities like gambling
aware that can help you if you are
addicted to a gambling check those out
on our website if you feel the need